hey everyone here and welcome back to
you know yet another episode of watching
The Watchmen this is a podcast that I
always say we do fairly you know
infrequently
it's kind of an on-and-off thing between
what was once a master and an apprentice
in the form of death but now you know
I've been somewhat eclipsed by his his
giant recaps but this is very much the
alan moore of the back catalogue so to
speak the more obscure part and for
those listening for the first time me
and definition have been reviewing the
entirety of watchmen have actually
finished that actually spoke to John
Higgins the colorist of Watchmen as well
one of the free guys have worked on it
and now you know we're gonna look at
another artistic shade of this thing
that being the movie and deaf has a go
man yeah really good Tom really really
good I'm quite excited for this episode
yeah I know we do the comic a lot but
fans of my channel and they all know
that I love talking about movies so yeah
really really happy Tom alright so as
always just before we dive into the film
as always you can you know subscribe to
their channel as well if you listen to
this one assist on your phone or on
iTunes or on all the sort of different
platforms like that
get in touch of us as well watching The
Watchmen pod edgy more calm you know as
I said it's fairly infrequent so we
don't have like I said a weekly inbox
that we dive into and stuff we've got
some low listeners so you know obviously
we got none to go through today but when
we do a future episode we were still
Doomsday Clock as well for some reason
which is the sequel which we definitely
need to catch up was what as well but
I'm deaf let's go back to the beginning
because I myself I remember the first
time I saw this movie well you know I I
saw I saw when it came out that have
been traumatic there it was 2009 like
February March 2009 you read the book
before you saw it I had well see I was
seeing their way around I saw the movie
first yeah yeah and then because I was
gonna read the book but then they're
like oh they're bringing a movie out and
I was they are [ __ ] reading and so yeah
just watch that first it was about it it
was the same as the Dark Knight as well
I think
yeah just right okay so the earth abut
yeah it was definitely in that sort of
vein completely in that sort of era so
yeah had had read it had I think we
spoke at this on the show ages ago but
yeah I had gone on holiday in 2008 and
picked it up actually in the States
being aware of it being a family sort of
gravitas and I remember like I can sort
of mentally remember the way I was
processing when I first read it and
obviously was such a sort of shallow
read and I found it quite obscure and
beguiling but obviously you know [ __ ]
loved it and it is an absolute
masterpiece but yes I was aware of it
and then I remember being in the library
in sixth form and there was a copy of
Empire magazine and me and this girl
were looking for it and she had no idea
what watch was but you know obviously I
read Watchmen so I was hyper looking
forward to seeing this I remember going
to the Odeon after school it was like a
dark you know Tuesday evening I think it
was quite a pack screening and you know
ultimately I definitely you know I did
enjoy it and it was a good experience
even then but what were your first
impressions I remember watching the
trailer and it had the song by the
Smashing Pumpkins which were it's
something like the end as the beginning
is the beginning is the end it's got a
really weird name but I knew that song
because it was on the soundtrack for
Batman in Robin mm-hmm which are on that
they on that soundtrack there's two
different versions of the song that the
album starts off with the beginning is
the end is the end of the beginning and
the album ends on the end is the
beginning anyway whatever the name is
but I remember really strongly being
from the album and then to see DC using
it again I say I'm a bit unsure and I
remember seeing Archie pop out the river
and I just had this really dark tone to
it that I was just getting accustomed to
and like I said Dark Knight that dad
dropped the year before and Batman
Begins I wasn't massively a fan of at
the time and it seemed quite a dark
intriguing film that like watching this
bright blue guy walk around and it
really was intriguing and obviously had
been a comic book fan for quite a while
at that point
I would still like think quite a young
teenager and so I wasn't as well-versed
in the medium so I'd heard of Watchmen
before but I didn't know and it kind of
intrigued me and and yeah and you know
it was back then this was before there
was ten comic book movies a year so yeah
it was getting labeled it's quite an
event um and there's basically before
film and Watchmen I knew that it was
they deemed like you couldn't film this
book and so many times I think yeah I
was quite interested to see how it would
translate to screen um and yet will not
get into my thoughts yet but yeah was
quite excited for it and you know as we
say it has photo troubled history I
think Terry Gilliam was involved but
obviously yeah Zack Snyder and came to
the fore from you know a great sort of
you know some opening films from him but
let's just let's just jump into the
material because obviously anyone listen
to the podcast we've sort of gone
through the whole story in depth or take
and one of the things we've grown to
know best are the characters you know
that's one of the most exciting things I
think about adaptions and still to a
certain extent in comic movies it's like
how this character gonna look on screen
you know thinking yeah fan of Sri cently
has been like a huge success but then
there's like you know but a lot more
obscure ones obviously so yeah that's
what I was looking forward to again from
that magazine as well that's what I was
seeing that's what I was you know
encouraged by and I still think the film
in general is aged really well yeah I
think don't you think I don't I think
there's a few things I'll get to towards
the end that really look bad but from
the characters to the costume design you
know to the set I think it's really good
and another thing is there's like three
cuts of this film that exist and the
theatrical cut I think is quite
disappointing and but a lot of people
just tend to go to the director's cut
and which it is a lot better
I myself I watch the ultimate cut mmm
which is just it's hot it is quite hard
to keep up for the casual you are
imagine it and
I recently saw that Watchmen theatrical
cut was on Netflix oh I can imagine
that's what a lot of people tend to
watch obviously when you say you know
there's a three-hour version of this
film it's not something that a lot of
people are going to be that interested
in watching and but yeah the the
director's cut is basically it's got a
lot of extended scenes and shots and in
the ultimate cut has all of that and
tales from the black freighter
intertwining at the edit and it's a
three and a half hour film so that's the
version I watched I didn't watch it all
in one go and I did still really enjoy
it and I do think has aged really well
that there's some absolutely beautiful
shots in it and I think looks wise it's
probably the best cinematography that
Zack Snyder's had in the film I'm just
like watching the the funeral for the
comedian and the moment in Vietnam where
dr. Manhattan comes over the horizon
there's a lot of very iconic shots and
that is a credit to the source material
as well yeah it completely is and the
source material is played with it's
extended obviously it's not why I would
call a direct homage although there are
several sequences that I think you know
perfectly match that and again it is
exciting just as well to see the
characters to see how certain plots are
handled like I think for example the dr.
Manhattan Jon Osterman origin sequence
he's [ __ ] brilliant in this film I
think it's really well done and I think
there is a sort of poetic more esque
languishing on shots especially the
opening of Bob Dylan opening as well
which to me death that sequence so we
kind of had the comedian sequence yeah
you know that kind of what starts us off
but we I love how we open with the
yellow the triassic DC logos yeah it's
brilliant it's brilliant introduction in
the film I've actually got it on in the
background and just as we're talking now
and it's it's up to the comedian scene
for me and yeah it's just so it
perfectly captures the look of the comic
book from the off in such an amazing way
M
just the way opens on the button and the
unforgettable suck like excuse the pun
yeah but it's got an unforgettable
soundtrack yeah in this intro it's
really picture-perfect and also
highlights that this movie's gonna be
arguably one of the most comic-book
accurate films of all time just for how
on point this opener is I mean this is
peak Zack Snyder action with the
slowdowns and speed ups and you stop
doing them by Man of Steel and it sort
did become a gimmick but in this moment
it's just really enjoyable and just
watching the room gets smashed up as
well there's impact to it and there's
this destruction but there's also this
sort of ballet to the the choreography
yeah it's easy to follow and intriguing
yeah it's really well shot
um and it's something I think Nolan
lacked in his films
you needed that but the Batman movies
especially Batman Begins that the action
scenes not very well shot and I think
that's where Zack Snyder excels at and
which is why in Batman V Superman his
warehouse scene with Batman's really
well put together and probably better
than all of the scenes in Dark Knight
from an action standpoint um but this is
just a fantastic opener and it really
just it seems very down-to-earth and
then you get into the supernatural feel
of it and you get the NA style shot
advert and comedian just sits back
laughing smoking his cigar and it's not
really the quintessential superhero
opener but it's just it does set the
tone that this isn't you yeah everyday
superhero movie that there's gonna be
some very realistic aspects to it and
it's got just such good gravitas to it
that it does capture your imagination
and I really can't see a crack of the
film denying that this is a bad way to
open the film and you know we open with
the comedian our first appearance with
the comedian now what do you think of
Jeffrey Dean Morgan
carnation he Delta ma'am and I really
didn't know much about the actor till
probably about three years ago and and I
genuinely up until that point thought he
was an old man and just that did believe
he was in his 50s just for how
believable that he manages to portray
this old guy as it's just a fantastic
performance and he nails all of the
nuances he's arrogant he's very cruel
but he's smirking and you can kind of
laugh with him as well and he's also got
the the balance of like the the broken
side of the comedian and the dramatic
side way realizes that you know
everything's tragic in a way and I think
he does he completely nails it yeah and
the money shots as well that the blood
on the smile is handled perfectly
you know we've real care you know real
fans I hope it's a glossy take it's a
calm it would take but still very
visually stylish and definitely not to
hollow as well and I mean I'm not really
the biggest fan of like the Marvel
franchise for example by thinking of
Paris and it's quite bloodless to this I
think this is really alive and I love
and I think most people point to this as
being one of the highlights of the film
are the opening vignettes yeah I think
they're they're pretty much all
brilliant like I've just been watching
them now and the way they play with
history and obviously as a fan we're
appreciate everything we're [ __ ]
nerds we know that's dollar bill you
know core there you know we can sort of
anticipate all the shutter we realize
that you know watching the Watchmen is
somewhat obscured but I mean death you
can understand and I've read quite a few
reviews of this film this morning you
can understand the inclination of
critics to be like what the [ __ ] going
on what maybe is kind of hard to follow
if you know I've got the Bible behind
you yeah there's I can imagine that like
if someone was critical about this film
I wouldn't be like too argumentative
with them just because I can totally see
it from that point of view if you're not
a fan of this already and then you
probably won't be blown away by the
movie and just because of how
accurate it is to the source material a
lot of comic book movies these days that
take the idea and then adapt it from
there
whereas this is pretty stingy the the
comic book basically and whereas like a
read age of Ultron last week and the
book is completely different to the film
it's like the only thing they brought
over is the title the Dark Knight is
completely different to anything that's
been in a Batman comic before and
spider-man homecoming I'm just like or
pretty much all of the MCU they adapt
minor things wear and go in their own
direction whereas this is literally here
is the comic book filmed and Alan
Moore's name not mentioned in the
credits yeah I think yes to have his
name removed in me which is strange
though I haven't seen it but it's more
artistically felt by not being there in
a way yeah very more Dave is there and
there are some great shots as we say we
can't really get to all of them but I
love seeing comedian on the grassy knoll
I love seeing the Russian aggression
Kent stay as well andy warhol with Noel
Prince yeah there's also like a little
Batman he's egging there and with the
comic books we've got major historical
events like dr. Manhattan min JFK and
then the comedian assassinating him yeah
and it just so well done really really
nice a piece of cinema that you could
show anyone and I think they'd have some
appreciation for and I mean obviously
it's difficult to go for it scene by
scene but it is you know think this
opening I think it's absolutely
brilliant and it continues really with
the character introductions again I
think Rorschach here by mr. Haley is
outstanding yeah he's absolutely
brilliant the guy completely nails it
it's the some bad characterizations in
this film but this to me is the best mmm
he just completely knocked it out the
park every scene he's in he's very
believable
and Jackie Earle Haley like it's quite a
short guy I'm in real life watch
something with him in the other day and
he like
pretty much he was dwarfed by all of the
the other actors in the scene um but
here he's he's sort of a giant on the
screen almost for me just the
interrogation that he has with Malcolm
it's a beautiful character building
moment and I think that is by far the
best performance in the film from just
that scene alone he just comes across as
like such a hard-ass and then when he's
in the film like throwing boiling hot
fat other prisoners shouting I'm not in
here with you you're in here with me
it's just a fantastic performance and he
nails every aspect yeah even in the
abyssal of intimate moments where more
were characterized and more like Grunk
and just various sounds and stuff just
his manner
altogether you're right Russia is so
multifaceted with or without the mask
and yeah I love that even though certain
scenes are changed we will go through
that as we go into the you know the
whole take is one it reminded me a
little bit in general so watching this
first 15 20 minutes or so in certain
scenes where you get it's kind of like
Lord of the Rings where from the book
there are later you know there are lines
set by other characters that are given
to characters earlier on to sort of fit
yeah yeah and there are slight
differences but unless you mass I don't
think you had the book in front of you
you would care that much your mind that
much like looking at the badge getting
clean above the sidewalk and and
Rorschach walks by it and then you see a
pyramid by fan in opposite direction I
that is exactly how the book opens and
in seeing that play out it was just all
coming together beautifully for me for
just how accurate it was and it's
amazingly recreated and on the extended
cut I don't know if this is in the
theatrical one but on the extended cut
it pulls out and after the button zoom
in and you just get an extended view of
the entire city and with a Ganga Diner
blimp and yeah it just works so well at
establishing that
yes the Watchmen is here on screen it's
here stay yeah it's like it's again sort
of knowing wing to the audience really
just to establish that you know they
they preach like when these directors
cuts happen you know it's a wonderful
thing and especially with this it's
great to see and it makes you realize as
you go through that so much stuff is
unfortunately melded together or skipped
over and it you know it never can be
that certain way and you know there are
lots of minor performances as well that
are demanded of the book that I think
are very strong Hollis Mason for example
yeah fantastic yeah the guy who doesn't
does a really good job has just playing
like an old guy who's a bit down on his
luck where he's still smiling in his
death scene later in the film I think
one of the best moments in in the movie
and just watching him sort of imagine
that he's going out in a big blaze of
glory and fighting the these hoodlums
that are actually his his previous net
enemies and it's just so well done
really really is good and he's actually
in the extended cut a lot more when you
have the black freighter moments that
intercut the film he's often buying the
new like there's a bit where he buys the
newspaper from the the stand yeah and
then we cut down to the the guy reading
a comic book
and he's fleshed out beautifully here um
and his death and his life it's probably
the way that most superheroes would live
and they sort of have their the big
moment in the spotlight and and sort of
die down as they get older and then but
they're really hungry like have a good
death and I keep talking about Batman
but like in the Dark Knight Returns one
of the big quotes is like this will be a
good death and it sort of talks about
how Bruce Wayne he he's an old man and
he really does want to go out in a blaze
of glory
and I think Hollis symbolizes that as
well he wants to go out like remembered
doesn't want to be just dying in his bed
one day and there's a real nice poetry
to his death
that kind of recaps the greatest and
proudest moments of his life and I don't
that I don't think it's in the
theatrical cut either hmm and the cuts
of like Moloch I think they just kind of
beat him yeah I should have really
watched that the auricle cut Tom should
know before I start slugging off and
saying this is an it there's lots of
subtle changes like I think I said to
you before like there's a huge article
the certain moment certain seconds will
have an extra seat you know it's not
even just narrative stuff it's just
certain lingering stuff as you mentioned
before and yet what did you think of the
the younger Noel dan dreiberg yeah
really really good I think he nails what
he's given but polite Patrick Wilson is
a really good actor but I don't like him
and Laurie I just feel like that kind of
met like all of their bits especially in
the ultimate cut which was already long
enough I was thinking like oh yeah this
is kind of like even though I'm quite a
big fan of this work it's it is really
dragging mm-hmm
and yeah it's just it's by far the least
intriguing aspect of the story so whilst
I think he does a good job I don't think
he's given much to work with um I really
let his acting shine he's kind of a
loser
I mean he's let down though boy Laurie I
agree I think Malin Akerman sucks in
this film yeah I mean I think she does
okay but I'm not one of her like worst
critics cuz I know a lot of people think
she's absolutely horrendous and sort of
ruins the movie and but she's okay to me
but yeah nothing amazing yeah he's just
told more about her because you probably
got more liked for me she's just there
yeah yeah no I mean you know again it's
the same thing yeah that's the criticism
I think it's a shallow take on Laurie
really as a character I know she's
written in that stereotype that mold buy
more to sort of fit the whole thematic
heft of the Watchmen as a unit and as a
very meta knowing book but yeah I just
felt a lot of this stuff especially on
MA
I think a lot of this stuff fell flat
for her I don't really had the range for
it I think the special effects were poor
as well when she's in that sort of yes a
life are the price I actually think the
worst is karnak when they get to Conoco
saw the smooth on the birds model yeah
they do use a lot of miniatures for that
and i do go or you mean actually yeah
but yeah the glass prison on in 4k tom
on it on it tell you what on a 55 inch
screen like that all not good night i
tell you that one but put that 4k away
you know it's more was so right when he
said something along the lines of like
you know it or everyone sort of said
it's an impossible to film book because
it really does kind of revel in what
comics can do like we get to see doctor
man out and go through time are you go
through panels you know later on that we
don't get to go we all the ironic
narration how many times on the show did
we use the word juxtaposed yeah exactly
you don't quite capture it's not very
juxtaposition or feel no it kind of is
yeah like a lot of the panels in
Watchmen are repeats of earlier panels
and where you kind of see the mirrored
and people sort of playing off things
that have happened in the past and
whereas you can't really do that in the
film unless you position everything
perfectly so they do miss quite a lot of
those like panels sometimes perfectly
cut with one another like we we said how
the black freighter beautifully ties
into like a sign in the real world and
yeah they don't really do that in the
film no em in the black yeah sorry go on
no no I for me it was more definitely
that is impossible I completely agree
yeah but in terms of the they can still
have a certain eye for detail like in
headlines in the back or you know I
think when Sally gets the the Tijuana
Bible yeah no that's true yeah yeah I
think that looks she's that looks pretty
good yeah she's um I think she does
quite a good performance as well yeah
the old lady makeup hasn't held up that
well but she does a good performance and
she was recently in the Horning of Hill
House on Netflix
okay which is a really really good show
so yeah it was nice actually seeing her
pop up again be like ah that's where it
will remember her from but obviously the
main character that we need to speak
about is dr. Manhattan yeah Billy Crudup
who is in rockstar which is a movie that
I really like with Mark Wahlberg and um
he gives a really good profit to stomp
line and I love yeah the thing is like I
I really liked him in this movie and
then everything he's done since I've
always kind of been like mmm so we've
met like alien covenant was probably the
last thing I watched him in okay um and
he was just sort of very met but he does
a fantastic job tom credit where - he
does a brilliant job with this he plays
it very monotone and but he completely
nails it and it is exactly what you sort
of think dr. Manhattan would be like
when you read the the comic and his
body's all CGI is well Tom he didn't
work out that hard you know
yeah and the guy who actually did the
body double got died because he got hit
by a train damn yep so a trivia there
for you Tom I know the fans have come
for the trivia and that's why I get all
the subscribers because their info like
that Tom he looks [ __ ] incredible in
this film though like I'm really crazy
about you know how they've shown him
here like it's and if you look closely
at his skin it's translucent there's
veins moving so yeah a nebulous he has
kind of his own I don't know his own
skin's like this universe you can have
to see stars in it and so I don't know
if that's in the more version but I like
that addition yeah oh that's really
really good luck in the HDR on it as
well like the gist the glow that comes
off of it really like lights of the room
hmm
and the the for tell you what the 4k cut
is it's really nice-looking especially
because there's quite a lot of grain in
it um and I don't normally like films
with lots of grain I'm more about that
digital extra-sharp picture but just the
way it glows off
the screen it's really really nice and
when he when he uses as powers it's it's
really cat his really eye-catching mm so
if you get every girl 4k TV get this
disc Tom it's actually cheaper buying
the ultimate cut on 4k than it is buying
the normal blu-ray hmm so get it kids
and also subscribe what are your
thoughts on Aussie [ __ ] Tom I am
actually wrote quite a bit I thought it
was the weakest part of the film and in
all honesty really did not like the
performance at all I'm trying to look on
my nose is that who it is what else has
he done because in my own right yeah
he's feels like that kind of actor yeah
um
like I just throughout the film I just
feel like a lot of detachment from him
um and I don't feel like it's the
materials fault I feel like it's his
performance like it doesn't make him
engaging for me like every time he
delivers a monologue it's just kind of
like you see Rorschach I had to kill
them all yeah and like even when he
threatens the board he's just saying
like no you listen to me it just doesn't
feel threatening and for me it's the
weakest aspect of the film he just feels
a bit too soft spoken to really grab you
and you know honestly the the guy who
comes out the lift to shoot those
salesmen he feels like a more
threatening villain than a human dies to
me just like the way they won't tell you
what Tom the way the orchestrate that
guy's entrance out the lifts and with a
symphony and everything I was I well
this guy's the real villain right here
um I mean I mean they do kind of
foreshadow that he is the villain quite
well they when he says he's got a
suicide capsule before you again to him
so like how would he know Tom but just
this guy's performance and that wasn't
wasn't for me and what about the music
it's probably why I hate possum and ice
like a real Doomsday Clock it just
whenever I read Doomsday Clock and then
like the car yet he's in the new HBO
series as well
he played by Jeremiah
oh yeah oh yeah I think I think Jeremy
Irons will nail it
mmm always like yeah yeah I think this
guy's doing like a Jeremy Irons light
yeah sure where is efficiency yeah we
did I'm sure I read somewhere that it
was originally us human dies were meant
to be based on Jeremy Irons Wow I don't
know but I probably made that up but
don't unsubscribe because keep subscribe
for more trivia like that yeah but the
music in the film obviously there's tons
of high profile songs probably the most
of every count in a film of like genuine
a list these songs are never on films
happens most on Suicide Squad Tom I have
entire films like a music video Wow
but no not for any reason not like they
use the songs in here to paint the time
right just like yeah just buying a song
in to bang a song in but I mean what do
you think of this as some people say
likes very um on the nose some of the
music musical cues yeah but I think it
works um yeah it's a I'm ready player
one have a bit weather like you like
disco music and the play like Saturday
Night Fever stayin alive and say oh my
god I love this song how did you know
say yeah is probably the most disco
music song of all time it is sort of
that but I like it I like the flight of
the Valkyries um yeah Vietnam I think
that's brilliant
um the Bob Dylan one brilliant yeah I've
got no problem with the music in this
Tom had evinced go so far as to say it's
a good soundtrack yeah yeah III enjoy it
is slightly a bit too obvious as opposed
but it works in the canvas they paints
definitely tell you what's a good music
Tom dr. manhattan's origin story that is
really yeah that that I think is really
well dealt with as well I remember they
used that music in the grand theft auto
4 trailer yeah brilliant a little piece
just talk about music sorry
our theme tune which I took from the
Watchmen OST it's called the American
dream
it plays during this film whether if you
heard it when comedian completely get
some Archie and starts firing into the
crowd you know you're looking at the
American dream it happened it's from
that so Chad I see well brilliant scene
that's where the woman drops the f-bomb
doesn't shoot um no um what unit back
one of the worst scenes that stood out
to me that also stands out in the book
as most memorable and horrifying at the
same time is a comedians rape yeah not
everyone's favorite scene for a good
reason I think it works though it really
does get you hate in this guy and one of
the key characteristics of this film is
it's very bloody and very very gory and
just watching him like smash her head
off the table it's just yeah to it it's
a bit nasty or watch Tom it is let's you
know this ain't the this ain't the comic
book movie for you kids go back and
watch your Rocket Raccoon and stuff like
that yeah yeah it kind of has the you
know the more adaption approach there
that undoing it a belt buckle but it is
completely vicious it kind of goes away
from the I think this is shot in the
book that's like a kind of it's a
reflection in molix Hell me or something
like yeah yeah conqueror of all those
but then everybody go for that but but
yeah honey justice comes in all the same
and yeah I like that scene but also hate
that scene like completely agree air it
is a uncomfortable watch like it's dog
dr. Manhattan's origin scene then
brilliant right yeah perfect I'm just up
at the bit now in the film where he's
gone through Vietnam just moving his
hand and these people's gutter getting
ripped apart and you getting the feeling
that this guy's of God
so it really piques your interest um and
the the dr. Manhattan origin scene
literally you could just cut out and
show show it as like an example of
amazing cinema
especially in a comic book movie I think
it's probably one of the best comic book
movie scenes um it's just this like I
said the scores fantastic
it also perfectly demonstrates dr.
Manhattan's view of time and his life
before his abilities and it also gives
like what he why he's so detached that
we forget that he's lost so much in his
life that he probably would just be
removed from emotion and not wanting to
get tangled up in human affairs due to
the fact that he's immortal and anyone
that gets close to will eventually die
and the effects have just seen him
getting ripped apart and then building
himself then the nervous system is just
a fantastic piece of CGI yeah and it to
me it's where the film really steps up a
gear um and you know the the dr.
Manhattan probably would have been quite
difficult to put the film in anyone
else's hands but the Snyder nails it and
I was talking about the HDR before time
trying to sell copies of this 4k disc if
you can yeah
but the HDR in this scene it's
absolutely incredible when he when he
comes into that canteen it's phenomenal
Tom get yourself on Amazon through my
affiliate link and buy that bloody 4k
disc lads yeah it's it's perfect really
as Alan I don't really have an affiliate
link Tom I'm not that famous yeah
there's nothing better because I want
some free stuff NSB exclusive news this
world--that slightly on the till there's
always Petrelli this way I don't think
we see any four-legged chicken or gay
couple in the dinosaur the certain
things they miss the blue dish there for
example there's lots of things they hate
the action figures I think you know it's
it will always be the most faithful
adaption it's crazy the amount of
delicate care that Snyder and koper into
this yeah too much care to the point
that it's sort of the rails like the
fact that this is a movie and yeah you
know I mean it's kind of like go it's
like Cara
in scene and tableau to tableau and it
doesn't have a natural flow yeah exactly
because it's adapted directly from a
book um which it works fine in a comic
because you've got chapters you but here
it's just like oh I don't know if you
should have put that in suck you
literally put the guy sitting in the
living room or a kitchen eating beans
for ten minutes on this ultimate cut
Snider do you need to do that though is
that what we need and then I'll turn
around go yeah you do need that you need
a goal through the affiliate link and
pine um so yeah a bit too much in bit
unnatural um one of my criticisms of
Batman V Superman is that they go
absolutely ages without an action scene
mmm and I think Watchmen is also guilty
of that it's just not it's not paste
know the way that film should be in a
book it's fine pacing like that have as
much drama in a book as you want but
don't have any action scenes in it's
fine movie totally different needs
something here need some high moments
need some low moments dynamically the
movie doesn't quite have that it's all a
very consistent tone except for a few
pops such as the dr. Manhattan such as
the opener the doctor man hadn't seen
Rorschach sell a prison fight and not
that ending because it's quite
downtrodden yeah I agree I don't think
the endings very good I think Karl as I
said before looks quite quite insipid
really from the outer rim and I agree or
so are you saying about Ossie before I
don't think the performance
he's a very good at all it's certainly
not the charisma and relish that I read
in the book and yeah Chad - Matthew good
man would Prince Margaret in the crown
good performance good series someone out
there needs to do a good [ __ ] podcast
on the crown maybe one day maybe a
listener but yeah the I think I think
for me ultimately those final scenes you
know those showdown scenes when the
plots revealed you know the characters
fighting Manhattan intruding from the
roof I
little they're not bad at all but I
don't know there's something about them
a bit of a disconnect
yeah I totally get that and I think it's
just a bit because it's all over the
place like basically the the final
action scene is raw shutting down
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
themselves and then dr. Manhattan
walking around slowly for a bit yeah and
then Rorschach walks away and gets
killed and that sort of like the the big
action scene to end on like a film to me
last half-hour wow it's gonna go off Tom
you know Captain Marvel I already know
the last half-hour that films gonna go
off this doesn't really do that so as a
film as a fan I'm loving it but as a
film I can see why people don't yeah
what do you think is the best ending is
it the book or the film don't know why I
did that like I probably I probably
prefer the call me the wand I would say
oh really even the big vagina alien yeah
I find it so obtuse and I liked its
construction in this odd Island with
this philosopher and mine therapist and
artist and yeah I just like the you know
barbarity of that but but yes still I'm
like the Manhattan ending I think it's a
nice Hollywood ending it's quite smart
ending you know I think it's a better
ending personally like I like the way
that it ties the whole story together
and where is the vagina alien and it
just seems a bit left-field for me and
it also seems to like logically I just
couldn't see humans believing it for
very long and that's probably why
Doomsday Clock that the smash hit
Doomsday Clock has been made and whereas
people were already living in fear of
dr. Manhattan in both the film and the
comic book so it makes a lot of sense to
have that fear kind of capsized in
unites the world against him
and so it really really does work for me
where is vagina alien don't know still
don't know but maybe that's because I
saw the film first yeah it's it's hard
to tell
yeah it is hard to tell and I think
ultimately the biggest part of me that
enjoys this film is the part that loves
[ __ ] Watchmen to begin with like
seeing it on the big screen and you know
I'm never gonna know obviously what I
would have fought but from what I gather
that's the general consensus I totally
understand that as well and you know
it's nice to go through and compare
dialogue as I say and scenes and you
know the the the I for the attention is
immaculate and you mentioned the
ultimate cart with the black freighter
which I actually haven't seen I think
I've seen a little bit of the black
friar all together yeah but that is a
[ __ ] ballsy movement that is an
artistic flourish there like are lovely
did that yeah it's really really good it
doesn't always work perfectly like the
scene where Rorschach's the the first
scene that it pops up is just after the
scene that Rorschach's walking along and
he does the Pagliacci speech yeah and
the very famous speech and then she cuts
to black and then it's just some guys
opening um and it's sort of the
silhouette sort of fade and you see that
it's a guy like lying face down in water
and and it's the the black freighter guy
and when he swims to the surface he sees
his mate
who's and this is different from the
comic book yeah he has like a
conversation with someone else who's
shipwrecked ever they drown and the
sailors voiced by Gerard Butler and
beautifully like it's beautifully drawn
and the sounds amazing the animation the
colour they use as well it really did
make me like the black freighter and but
they do change it like a fair bit and
basically he drags the guy's body too
sure that he was having a conversation
with in his corpse it's sort of in a
sort of American Werewolf in London sort
of way yeah
verse Asians with that sort of gives us
inner thoughts on the situation and then
it follows story-wise and follows the
same route as the EM the comic book does
with him landing on a river on it so
deserted island building a ship out of
corpses and sailing across the seek and
attacked by sharks arriving back home
and killing killing his family killing
that guy at the shore he was a con man
Tom you remember the guy and then
swimming out to sea and joining the
black freighter I think in actually in
the book did not leave it ambiguous that
we didn't know if the black freighter
existed or not sure and but here it
definitely exists and it talks about how
it does tie in quite nicely to the
Ozymandias mentality where he set out
with the best intentions to return home
and save his family from the black
freighter but it's just he just went a
bit mental along the way Tom and who can
kill everyone
lovely guy though I'm sure if you meet
him in person and but they also had a
lot of extra scenes with the comic book
vendor in a really a nice he's barely in
it yeah he said so in the ultimate car
he's probably in for about ten minutes
mmm him in the comic book guy that they
have lovely little lines and they also
have something that sets up the Hollis
Mason murder so basically the first
scene that you see them in Hollis
Mason's walking past and he buys a
magazine and then it kind of the camera
fades off him and goes towards the
vendor in the guy reading the comic book
and then at another point he's the comic
book guy sitting down and some not tots
pair some top knots come up the stairs
and like stop bullying him and the news
vendor guy sticks up for him and then
the next scene I think the the top knots
come up again of the the same way and
they're just about a bullion but then
they find out about Hollis Mason to go
and kill him and
then organelle this is like one of me
Endon explained videos comm they see the
and then the news vendor guys like oh
just keep it just keep it which is
really nice but because we've guys a bit
of a [ __ ] he like throws in his face
that doesn't have an ending so when the
doctor Manhattan explosion does happen
at the end of the film you have sort of
had a build up towards this and Malcolm
also pops up towards the end to buy
something off the news vendor and which
is when the bomb goes off because if you
remember in the film and Malcolm's there
in the explosion and it's suitcase opens
and all the yeah that's sort the
valuable oh yeah the ink blots yeah
so that's padded out a lot more um but
yeah it's really nice if you like three
and a half hour long films tom with
completely pointless scenes in them yeah
we had a love dates there and the forty
burn could have been an extra long go on
I'm sure as well yeah you know must be
an incredible amount of scenes than they
[ __ ] did for this face yeah that's
the thing like Snyder literally filmed
everything pretty much like that I
haven't got around watching it yet but
there's also the under the hood mmm
documentary on there the disc as well em
and I think that's about half an hour
long so they just filmed like everything
for this this movie
probably because Snyder has not got an
original idea on his body but yeah good
if you like Watchmen if you don't if you
just a casual fan don't buy from the
affiliate link fans I'm being honest
with you I feel like we've gotten to
know each other through this podcast so
I'm gonna be your friend now and say do
not buy ultimate cut through my
affiliate link so um rich just exists so
the final four words then death on the
watchman adduction I'm a bit annoyed Tom
because I wrote eight pages of notes
right and not really talked about we're
not talking about the awkward sex scene
yet Tom that's true that's true do you
want to talk about energy okay let's
talk about that yeah what do you think
about it when they play hallelujah over
the top of them haven't
again again it's very quiet garish for
me I remember as a youth finding it
quite arousing but now quite comical
really and outrageous as well that I
mean there's a lot you just say you
found it arousing yeah I would say so
yeah
Malin Akerman right yeah yeah and you
know I found the scene no it's just
where it goes on too long there's no
real subtlety to it I don't think it was
very over-the-top and the prison riot
that follows it that's quite good
like the little guy on fire and that's
not CGI Tom that's a little Deadpool to
reference for the fans out there and I
like when I really like when Rorschach's
or wipes out all of the prisoners and
that guy gets his arms caught yeah when
he's things a car for the race yeah that
was me it's brilliant he confronts
Malcolm and and again like Jackie Earle
Haley completely nails his role and you
seen him pull the mask down over his
face it's just great
yeah yep brilliant brilliant movie top
it is I don't know how its core it she
would do some scores do you want to talk
about Rorschach dyin what an emotional
gut punch you actually watched the the
director's cut with my wife a couple
years ago at Richter and he doing it Tom
and she was genuinely shocked that they
killed Rorschach at the end yes we good
devastated Tom worse comments death ever
yeah him get made into a nice little
Rorschach paint he'd I don't think is it
in the comic no it's not no but I mean
what we don't see in that so Snyder is
better than were officially he's
personally sorry as though as a wink to
Moore it looked a little bit like a
butterfly to me which obviously is a
hallmark of this whole act of Watchmen
but but but yeah I mean I'm not gonna
say the rewatch this I was as glued as I
was I've recently watching the work of
Pedro album of our the Spanish director
he did Julieta which some Netflix which
you would hate by the way I would
recommend it to you but I don't I don't
think you would I think maybe would be I
don't know maybe maybe you're like it
maybe we could talk away but people he
doesn't hate and didn't that meet
because actually I think these days a
woman's daughter goes missing and then
she eventually sort of finds out where
she is so yeah bearish Tom spoil it for
me yes no sort of religious commune in
the hills
okay Lucia so um so yeah but but but
still it was good to watch it definitely
and to go back and also to sort of just
look at Watchmen again because I [ __ ]
loved you know I was going through and
people go back and check out the
episodes that we did I think so we did
12 episodes but a lot of them were like
an hour and a half an hour and 20 so
probably like 50 now we watch one yeah
exactly
Tom so it was pretty much ruined
Watchmen for ourselves haven't we like I
know you're not happy about Doomsday
Clock and we're sort of crushed all our
hollow for it but it was nice this last
little hurrah watching the film and
because it is so faithful yeah um does
the director's cut up the guy at the end
with the hotdog splashing on the t-shirt
Tom yes it does you right I'm just like
it's that accurate it's pretty much bang
on yeah like I've been quite negative in
my notes Tom I was really positive but I
didn't get to do them all sure I did I
don't think I did a quarter of my notes
and but really I was really positive
when watching it like it was difficult
for me as a fan that knew what was going
on to find fault with the film um Snyder
he does a fantastic job of putting
together a film that many have said you
couldn't film it um and he did this Tom
by basically filming the entire thing
and I think that definitely that point
really stands out in the ultimate
because everything's in there if you
can't be bothered to read the boot guys
just gather Olynyk up and you'll you'll
be sorted
and it is literally the book on film for
three in a bit hours but I enjoy it it's
not something that I regularly revisit
but it is one of my favorite comic book
films of all time
it certainly is the the most accurate
and oh ever so yeah if you've only seen
that the article cut I probably
recommend that you get the director's
cut to be honest and I think that the
out record cuts far too short and it
misses out a lot of the the subtext and
the little the little moments that
really just highlight how accurate this
is and the old limit cuts probably too
long for most people like aha watch into
settings because that was it was stolen
away
I remember being two hours in um and it
would think it was like Laurie and Dan
had just decided to they hadn't even
become superheroes yellow and that's how
long the film is and yeah and it's a bit
long for most people know I do enjoy but
it's only for the most hardcore fans of
the film who want the little incident
they want to see the black freighter Tom
they want to see the comic-book guy most
people that probably don't give a [ __ ]
mm the probably who the hell is that
character why is he relevant Tom and
I'll tell you why it's relevant because
he sits there and reads that book that
has that thing in that originally was
deemed not good enough to be in the film
so there it worked on a different level
entirely for us because of this show and
because of our fandom we were just
seeing it through that paradigm and it's
similar to bodied which I know you'll be
familiar with yeah it's a big film at
the moment about battle rap which means
they have covered extensively as well in
the past and directed by the guide to
the toxic music video and written by kid
twists blower so I'm very very cool
movie but yeah there's loads of cameos
in that as well so watching all the
songs which by Britney Spears toxic by
Britney Spears yeah great music video
right more than watch it now yeah cuz
the tasty your lips Sam on around come
on some people that was there
Orion Dan you know that was the same
year that was after tattoo though that
wasn't it
oh wow what what I knew she did not walk
away though but but yeah I mean
obviously yet there's so much in this
[ __ ] film there's so much material
that they recorded like the Nixon stuff
I think is dealt with well he's quite a
recurring character do you think I don't
like the yeah yeah just the nose like a
lot of films have their there Nixon in
um ya know this happen soon happen
recently like you watch that yeah it's
just it still the nose is just too over
the top and the best one I've probably
seen in recent memory is Days of Future
past hair but yeah this one it was a bit
[ __ ] I thought Tom in a film that's
quite grounded from the most part it
just seemed very strange yeah yeah there
were lots of little things as well like
there was a moment on a chat show
I forget who was on it now but basically
they were speaking to a host that looked
like Dick Cavett who was very much a
sort of Jimmy Kimmel Jay Leno of his day
so yeah you know there were lots of
little genuflect ins back to nostalgia
throughout and yeah it is an incredibly
faithful without and that's kind of the
f-word know you say juxtaposition but no
it's accurate faithful but it really is
the level of you know empiricism very
similar to back to Messrs Gibbons and
more is it's quite outstanding really
and I love the fact that they did this
and regardless of what Sir Linda laughs
you know upcoming miniseries and HBO is
like I don't think even if it is going
to do our Marge's which you're probably
will do in some sort of way it will get
close to a lot of these a lot of these
were absolute artistic bull's-eyes I
think in terms of depiction and I
repeatedly applause the film foot
applauded the film for that but yeah as
a piece of sort of classic film
literature to me it's not something on
necessary gonna happen all the time but
it was it was fun to go back and
no I've got to say it's very impressive
yeah definitely like size and scope of a
really good and it still holds up looks
fantastic
acting on the most part really good
couple of duds in there tom mainly the
villain which is obviously one of the
most important parts of the film you
know a bit of bit of extra care on the
car
it's weird cuz Snyder worked with Jeremy
Irons as well Batman V Superman in that
yeah in yeah he could have gotten for
this Tom I'm sure he would have done it
this was you know he hadn't he didn't
work that much after die hard three I
don't think anyway they not do Dungeons
& Dragons may have done if he isn't that
ending world it yeah so Snyder probably
could have gotten and but yeah what what
version would you recommend watching ah
well it is the director's cut really
that I'm most familiar I just think the
theatrical cut to lacking too much hmm
what is the ultimate cuz it's just as
it's just the this like there's so many
little things missing there's literally
hundreds and hundreds of little things
missing and the directors cuts in
general are pretty much Bob one film I
can think about I prefer to the
theatrical cut um the the film that
don't prefer is Leon because there's
like scene in that way um they imply
that he's a pedophile okay and I'm like
well don't imply the the lead man it's a
beautifully I'll be I've seen I thought
a few times but I didn't know that yeah
and it's it's not a good director's cut
but other than that the sauce yeah we're
talking aliens were talking Terminator 2
talking everything that might be
Superman I'm just trying to think about
a basically the amount of films that are
bought on blu-ray when they've come out
at the cinema and then six months later
be like we're bringing out the extended
cut of er what and then boring it's much
better Days of Future past the extended
cuts way better than the theatrical one
just it just paints a bigger picture Tom
so yeah director's cut all the way
unless there's the ultimate cut
available on Amazon link in the
description what some obviously outside
of this as well
we both do channels you know go support
be our our alphabet a Laker goes for
watching the Watchmen of course as well
def has a channel do a man you you're
like a [ __ ] viral superstar over here
some [ __ ] I got an email a day table
from YouTube saying congratulations on
10,000 subscribers Wow which I didn't
think I could get but it's so amazing
not like PewDiePie yet but I've listened
to the last episode last night and I've
doubled my subscribers since then so
selling out big time
ya guys and just want to thank yous for
doing it I've also as a thank you Tom
note to the fans
I've actually done a video I'm giving
away a free copy of hereditary and all
you have to do is go on the video in the
comment write your top five films of
2018 and I'm gonna pick a winner you've
probably got a good chance of winning
because they're only three people event
at so far so you definitely got a chance
there Tom you get yourself I'll get
probably well never oh yeah yeah so I'll
just give you a way to give something
back but I have it's been great and you
know really appreciate everyone who
keeps subscribing because every day when
I wake up this morning Tom I thought I'm
gonna wake up and have a it's a nice
relaxing morning where I don't have to
do any videos because I know that
nothing's out anyway they drop the
[ __ ] Captain Marvel trailer Tom so I
do that 8 o'clock this morning before I
start at work and yeah and it wasn't fun
so what about your stuff Tom it's going
good man it's going good I mean you know
not it's kind of it's tough really
because this obviously the subject I
cover is far more niche not not to
compare but it's I can't really go viral
the top 10 king of a dot fails or some
[ __ ] but I but you know in terms of
content you know this is ration it we're
doing live bass
the mind and stuff like that so you know
yeah some cool stuff out there but no no
she enjoyed listening to my humor no
seriously though man like it is crazy to
see how you've grown bro you know it's
very very cool and you know this will be
on the channel as well so this is gonna
be yeah and in the street Paul Walker
all the people who we subscribed since
the last episode all 5,000 of them are
gonna be like what the [ __ ] is this so
I'm glad I can disappoint them all ID
cards Eric Ferguson oh yeah of course
ma'am probably our faithful list now I'm
sure I've got loads of comments on the
last should we read out some comments
have you got somewhere I go top we got
somewhere to go I've got a look for the
video you stole Tom you stole for the
listeners I know it's not good having
silence on no no so yeah go find out and
everyone needs to go back on the channel
as well and check out all the other
episodes that we've done and all the
times that death has obviously been on
battle route resume as well we are gonna
get deaf on battle resume again really
soon to basically do definition sort of
fixes UK battle rap right I found it Tom
all right all right you can stop talking
about stuff right I haven't a jet once
though okay cyan-blue this is on
Doomsday Clock issue 7 blind spot review
and analysis
go get those key words and that that
tail tom great video I agree on the
series I was hyped a lot before I came
out and it didn't deliver one of the
things I dislike about the story from
Jeff Jones is that it's not a standalone
story like Watchmen characters like
satin girl Johnny Thunder will be hard
to understand all their importance if
you're not familiar with them from the
comics this story ties into other
stories from rebirth and as a standalone
the story will be hard to understand
like things like certain characters or
white characters are important and I
thought this story was just on it keep
basically thinks that it's quite a long
Cohen he thinks it should be standalone
what do you think Tom cyan-blue
yeah I think unfortunately it takes
place
in the DC universe is a DC Universe
crossover event so it is gonna have to
inherit some of those tropes which
personally I hate like I'm a bit of a
you know stickler really I'll just read
sort of collected hermetically sealed
image additions I don't really like my
crossover and you know excel see or you
know check out issue 66 whatever like
you know I don't really appreciate that
and that is a stumbling block that we
came across when we've done Doomsday
Clock so far and if you just do a Stan
Lee joke Tom it's too [ __ ] soon if
you did I was genuinely devastated when
that guy died of course ma'am my wife
she reads the Daily Mail Tom yeah don't
don't tell any don't let anyone know
that because it's [ __ ] horrendous
paper but anyway she get two
notifications on iphone and she was just
settling to and he Stanley's died and my
first words were [ __ ] off Ben
[ __ ] off what devastated and he won't
continue
there are definitely r.i.p stanley of
course we hadn't we hadn't discussed
this you know i've seen incredible
legend and i thought if you listen to
Kevin Smith yeah and beyond rate podcast
yeah yeah amazing podcast we vet loads
of times we spoke about Mark been our
Dean as well on this show actually in
the past cuz you know he is fire
breaking out story got so much respect
for that guy but yet they didn't you
should be doing my youtube channel
really shouldn't he's doing bigger
things man I mean it's fun things do you
to get an email a day from YouTube about
10,000 subscribers Tom what what do you
mean there's bigger get back to you on
your right a Netflix series homie yeah
alright a great guy though that any what
any more comments mom sorry for directly
near that Tom you were gonna say
something nice about the guy and I'll
start I'll not interrupt you next time
cuz I feel like and while we're taking
you Eric put one month ago
thanks again it's a pleasure to listen
to you the only reason to buy Doomsday
Clock is to listen your program
really
recommend we should put that it's the
only reason to buy besides I think
Batman in Doomsday Clock has Alzheimer's
poor man
funny that dr. Manhattan says at the end
I do not see tomorrow would it be about
Doomsday Clock greetings from Amsterdam
hmm Kevin Lynch loved your reviews of
Watchmen haven't read any of Doomsday
Clock forget some good laughs I were
listening to you guys talk about it I
bet he loves those Alan were
compressions Tom he's won him up he's my
only patreon Tom Kevin Lynch shout him
out he says I still see I see I'm still
your only patreon what the hell's going
on well I tell you what Kevin if you
still have patreon cancel that because
I've not seen any money from that and I
emailed them saying what the [ __ ] is
going on I know this guy's donating
where's this money going and them not
replied Wow so [ __ ] that God and Ikey
well don't [ __ ] that lad [ __ ] Adriano
daga that was a nice comment definitely
actually we're about to leave I think
I'm not hitting the threshold yet for
them to give me money
mm-hmm I checked on the email actually
and we did get one from Eric quite a few
months ago I've got two patreon x' oh
there we go
and a ride that chomsky so shout-out to
them as well yeah but it isn't a letter
pledging anything it just looks like
they're watching them we're watching The
Watchmen on there they're watching the
page world exactly yeah but that's doing
all right though innit Tom I'm here know
what guys give if you want to donate the
patreon bloody go over Tom's patreon I'm
doing alright got money off ads and
selling my soul so give that lad your
money you bastard so appreciate that man
we will put all the links down below for
the film every affiliate link and and
for everything else but yeah Eric got in
touch actually on the email he says
hello I think we read this one I don't
think we did actually and it's came a
little later hello in case you didn't
have the Watchmen or
module I have attached it so we'd spoken
about this before deaf so this is the
only thing after Watchmen that Alan
Moore officially was like Parv until you
want to review it yourself weren't you
oh yeah I think we still probably should
and because Erik's given us we could
just read it and just discuss it that
would be a that would be quite cool so
he said I used to have this module and
only recently gave it away in the night
net he's my group of friends we played
Dungeons & Dragons like games but not
actually D&D because we hated the rules
it turns out my neighbor was a nice time
many of the Mayfair models but not this
one one of the system's wix4 was a DC
one autumn Utley the rules and game
mechanics were just too unwieldy to my
surprise the module is considered Alan
Moore cannon [ __ ] me I think I learned
that from you I wish I hadn't given her
way but I gave it to a friend it has a
good home and then he talks about us
mentioning John Burns you remember who
that was I don't know it looks like John
Byrne was an artist who you mentioned
says I was surprised that you were both
not familiar with John Byrne who is
probably who mentioned him yeah he was a
very big name in the 1980s Byrne worked
with Chris Claremont on the classic
x-men Dog Phoenix saga okay cool his
work has not aged well he has some
controversial views by Fred in the 1980s
it was very difficult to learn about an
artist compared to now except elem Alan
Moore he let you know exactly how he
felt I think Neil Gaiman has the same
way anyway here's a link to an overview
of John Burns early work and yay says
anyway whatever you cover in your next
podcast wish you the best Eric yeah
brilliant I know are we doing Doomsday
Clock Tom I think I always sort of for a
bit of a hissy fit really I said didn't
you I said that I wasn't gonna do it I
just couldn't really move over to do it
but I think the thing is Tom when you're
in these podcasts it it's a right laughs
in it means good laughs as soon as you
hang up I've got a [ __ ] hate doing
them I hate that bastard I wish you'd
stop bugging me with these oh sorry go
hope you don't listen back to this and
think I can't believe you just said that
but yeah Doomsday Clock were in the near
so I'm actually I'm looking more forward
to reading before Watchmen hmm and
that'll tide well but and then you know
exactly what's gonna happen Tom the TV
show just as we're getting now the TV
show is gonna drop and it'll be like The
Hunger
games all over again I mean it that
think that that would be brief I guess
that would be like you know in over 12
weeks were over the other is still still
quite in a lot I started doing them
start doing The Walking Dead recaps on
Monday morning seemed like a good idea
at the time when I first started doing
it by the second one I was like bloody
hell I'm gonna have to do I'm gonna have
to wake up every morning at 5 o'clock
watch The Walking Dead and then do a
video about it every every week mam's I
tell you what these TV recaps Tom
they're not they're not all you think
they scare me those sort of things that
I already do a [ __ ] Metallica podcast
it's like week by week of life obviously
I love doing it baits like it is a
commitment what you say and you all
necessities and that you can throw up a
grudge it to a certain extent but it you
know it is fun at the end of the day so
um you know who I feel really sorry for
Tom that other Watchmen podcast are
doing it page by page Wow
that's dedication he's Daisy they look
for 300 pages how many pages is that
better not even out the first issue yet
I haven't listened to it cuz I'm gonna
[ __ ] those guys
twelve times fight like something like
that like there was a way to work that
out that's um Tom I think that's about
right um but yeah I remember I think I
think we shared this actually one system
in like that but it was like a an image
that showed you all the issues of
Watchmen in order as like a huge thing
you could see kind of what happened on
each page yeah [ __ ] me yeah that is that
I didn't get a huge respect to those
guys I need to listen to that actually
when that first came out I was a bit
like ah [ __ ] yeah I was a bit pissed off
as like these we do watch from pockets
but no big respect to those guys for
doing that definitely and there's a lot
of people who do and explain videos Tom
now and I [ __ ] hate them all but I
also really respect them and now that
we're through this I'm kind of like oh
you know what I do kind of respect those
guys maybe not the best idea going
through it page by page but hats off to
them yep yep so you've done Bevan I've
done
so yeah thanks as always guys appreciate
listening let us know getting on their
podcast they're sitting slugging us off
Tom no I don't run anyone's radar we get
we get show we get so little downloads
it makes me quite an ocean too sorry cuz
I think show is really good and it's
like I don't know why easily the best
thing on my channel yeah isn't saying
much no no if you enjoy the show yeah
shout out to a friend or something like
that
helper say it but still you know it's
very cool to go back through this man so
um yeah at any closing forts bro well
people are gonna look at this that the
length of this episode and be like oh
yes this talked about watch him in the
movie for an hour and 20 minutes and I
can't wait to listen to it little do
they know we'll talk about the movie for
about half an hour and then you sort of
ramble on about [ __ ] so guys if you've
stayed this long in the podcast thank
you for listening to the end of this
prove that you've done it by writing I
don't know what watching the write in
the comments Tom it's a good night from
me it's a good night from John Higgins
you